bis vor kurzem wusste davon kaum jemand
was zumindest außerhalb des
Regierungsviertels davon wie engmaschig
die familiären und freundschaftlichen
Verbindungen sind zwischen seine
Ministerium und Institutionen die die
Energiewende vorantreiben bzw begleiten
nun aber gibt es eine Wendung die den
Scheinwerfer auf all diese Verbindungen
richtet und Konsequenzen haben könnte
für ihn bzw sein vielleicht wichtigsten
Mann einen seiner Staatssekretäre die
Geschichte beginnt mit diesem
organigramm
zu Habeck 7 Staatssekretärin zählen sein
langjähriger Vertrauter von den Grünen
Michael Kellner und dessen Schwager
Patrick reichen dessen Schwester verena
ist mit Kellner verheiratet sie arbeitet
wie auch ihr zweiter Bruder Jakob
reichen für das Ökoinstitut das im
Auftrag des Wirtschaftsministeriums
Studien erstellt Verena greifen ist
zudem Vize-Chefin beim Umweltverband
BUND die vier treiben maßgeblich jene
Energiewende voran die Patrick reichen
einst entwarf als Chef der
Lobby-Organisation agora Energiewende
worum geht es es geht darum und nichts
anderes ist es letzten Endes unsere
Wirtschaft und Industriegesellschaft
komplett umzubauen für ein solch
gigantisches Projekt sind kurze Drähte
wertvoll und es gibt sie zu Hause Felix
mattes etwa ist forschungskoordinator
beim Ökoinstitut seine Ehefrau Berlins
frühere Umwelt in Naturin Regine Günther
leitet heute gemeinsam mit Rainer Barke
die Stiftung Klimaneutralität die
ebenfalls Politikberatung macht Barke
war früher selbst Staatssekretär sein
persönlicher Referent damals Patrick
reichen Barke gründete später agora war
dort also Vorgänger von gleichen und
wurde letztes Jahr zu dem von Habeck zum
Sonderbeauftragten für die deutschen
amiibische Klima und energiekooperation
ernannt
Verpflichtungen die in der Berliner
Grünen Szene nie ein Geheimnis waren so
Journalist Bernhard Pötter der über das
Familienprojekt der gleichens schon vor
anderthalb Jahren schrieb und diese
Konstellation wollten wir haben wir
transparent gemacht war auch kein
Problem dass Ministerium und die
Beteiligten waren da alle sehr
transparent haben gesagt so ist es und
wir sehen zu dass es die möglichen
Interessenkonflikte dass die
ausgeschlossen werden genau hier aber
setzt nun das Problem an obwohl die
Sensibilität bekannt war wurden die
derart betonten strikten Regeln nun
unterlaufen bei der Besetzung des
chefpfostens der bundesebenen Deutschen
Energieagentur kurz Dehner ausgewählt
wurde unter 18 Bewerberinnen und
Bewerbern Michael Schäfer Trauzeuge von
Patrick reichen der in der zuständigen
dreiköpfigen Findungskommission saß und
den Auswahlprozess begleitete
und damit ist das eben sozusagen da wo
der Fehler aufgetreten ist in dieser
Findungskommission kann eben der
Anschein einer Befangenheit nicht
ausgeschlossen werden könne der Anschein
von Befangenheit nicht ausgeschlossen
werden der Verein Lobby control
formuliert das etwas anders sieht
Patrick reichen gerade nach den
bekannten Verbindungen beschädigt er hat
als Staatssekretär eine klare
Vorbildfunktion wie solche
Interessenkonflikte zu managen sind wenn
es hier um einen engen Freund und Blick
Begleiter geht das hätte er transparent
machen müssen und dafür muss er dann
auch die Verantwortung tragen die Kritik
der politischen Gegner Ziel zu dem vor
allem darauf ab dass das
geschmecklehafte und die eigene nach
sich damit im krassen Gegensatz zum
sonst stets postulierten Anspruch stehe
in der Ampelkoalition insbesondere bei
den Grünen hält man sich für moralische
Überflieger macht aber genauso weiter
wie die Merkel Regierung
gibt es etwa aus der linken diese Woche
schon kurz vor bekannt werden der Diener
Personalie noch schärfer danach die
Kritik an Habeck aus der Union er hat
sich immer mehr eingeignet im Kreise von
denen die also ein Parteibuch haben aber
vor allem eben auch im
Verwandtschaftsverhältnis mit seinen
Staatssekretären stehen er ist nicht
Vorsitzender der Grünen sondern er ist
der Wirtschaftsminister der viertgrößten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt und so muss er
sich auch in diesem Ministerium
Verhalten bei der Auftragsvergabe von
Gutachten sei stets alles regelkonform
verlaufen Versicherter wechshausen
dennoch bröckelt auch ampelintern
allmählich der Rückhalt die FDP etwa
zeigt wie nah an einer
entlassungsforderung kommen kann ohne
sie auszusprechen ich habe nicht die
Aufgabe dem Minister irgendwelche
Vorgaben zu machen aber das Problem ist
virulent und er hat die Personalhoheit
und er muss das Problem lösen Harbeck
hat sich inzwischen geäußert zu seinem
Staatssekretär und lobte dessen
konsequente Art ohne die wäre
Deutschland Deutschland heute in einer
schweren Wirtschaftskrise bei der
Auswahl des Trauzeugen sei ein Fehler
passiert deswegen muss das Erfahren
meine Ansicht nach neu aufgesetzt werden
das haben wir dem
Aufsichtsrat der den er am Donnerstag so
mitgeteilt und die beraten das jetzt und
denke ich dass sie das auch ähnlich
entscheiden werden mit dann vermutlich
mehr Sensibilität für familiär
freundschaftliche Verbindungen als
jüngst auch die Initiatoren des
energieküste Worts den Habeck für seinen
unermüdlichen Einsatz in der
Energiewende erhielt eine Gesellschaft
aus Schleswig-Holstein deren Aufgabe die
Umsetzung jener Energiewende ist
überreichte den Preis konkret ihr
Geschäftsführer Hinrich Habeck Roberts
Bruder
[Musik]